[Music]
a google search
a youtube video a connectedness device
and hundreds of google cloud services
all give you a response in a fraction of
a second
but what really happens when you click
search send a request
or say okay google well your message
travels over the public internet and
into google's global fiber network
millions of these requests or packets of
data travel through miles of cable over
land and under sea converging at one of
the many data centers we operate
all over the world but besides
delivering quick results back to you
what exactly is a data center a data
center is a building with powerful
computers used to run a company's
services
it's where information is processed and
made available data is stored
managed and disseminated across these
computers and network infrastructure is
installed
to support web apps databases virtual
machines and more
often organizations start with their own
modest buildings
made up of a few server racks which
requires maintaining these systems
paying for cooling and handling
increasing demand
so many companies look to a cloud
services provider like google cloud
these providers data centers have
evolved into large campuses of multiple
buildings
hyperscale data centers made up of tens
of thousands of servers
process big data support cloud computing
and
serve billions of users for services
like chrome maps
gmail search and google cloud in the
cloud world
companies and users can benefit from
this skill because of a special thing
called multi-tenancy this means
customers can share the resources of
each server in a data center
like tenants sharing common resources of
an apartment building
each tenant's cloud systems are isolated
and invisible to other tenants
this means higher compute processing and
storage a more efficient use of data
center resources
and a much lower cost than if you manage
your own servers
google cloud customers can even deploy
resources in regions across the world
which are enterprise data center
locations with three or more zones
zones are the individual isolated
buildings on a data center campus
companies can deploy workloads across
multiple zones to help protect against
unexpected failures
something you can't always get with a
single private data center
it takes a right mix of energy cooling
and people
to keep a data center up and running but
it's a technical feat google's managed
to pull off to optimize for efficiency
scale and cost more on that next time on
discovering data centers
[Music]